hi Ted bellacor with reason TV the
Slamdance Film Festival at park city
utah what brought you to park city park
city i had been here in 2003 with my
film and i came back to support
Slamdance and to see bones here and it
son knows the kidnapping of ingrid
betancourt is a film that i made with my
co-producer victoria Bruce is 2002 we
were going to film the presidential
campaign a big ridge vent work in
Colombia as she was running for
president in 22 initially that was our
plan and then what happened it was she
was kidnapped by the FARC guerillas in
Colombia the leftist guerrillas soon
into her better pay and it's in February
2002 and at that point we decided to
follow her family and her campaign as
they
in absence and so we did make the film
and it was on HBO Cinemax and then that
was in 2004 that HBO broadcast it if we
worship them and then this summer wind
ingrid betancourt and other hostages
were released it was in july two
thousand eight when they were released
it was broadcast on CNN cents and now
HBO will have it for this year as well
in Columbia there are in addition to
there's the government and then there's
the leftist guerrillas who are the four
gorillas they've been around since the
60s and they live in most there's a lot
of them in the areas of the jungle areas
of Columbia and southern Colombia and
then there's also the paramilitaries or
the autodefensas and then there's
another guerrilla group called the ELN
and those are the main players there's
also gangs and other sort of people but
those are the main players I think that
in Colombia from what I've seen let's
take for example Bogota Colombia which
is the capital of Colombia I think that
people there that I have encountered
most people either no people involved in
the drug business and one way or the
other there's there's the range of
people there's the US contractors
working down
columbia who are working on the war on
drugs there are Colombian military who
are also the troops on the ground or you
know going and exploding the drug lab
searching for drug labs as our US
contractors searching for drug labs but
then there's also many people in the
rural areas I think are more touched by
it if they're in a cocaine coca growing
area through touched by it it's become I
mean drugs has become a thing that has
fueled a lot of quality and economy i
believe over the years when Pablo
Escobar was really big the cartels it
was a huge problem and now it's switched
to the other groups like the gorillaz
the paramilitaries who are involved in
the drug trade and I mean it's the money
that's pouring in there they I think
keeps the conflict going I think the
drugs be legalized let's say if cocaine
were ever legalized it would have a huge
impact on things because right now
what's happening is the US government is
giving billions of dollars to Colombia
to fight the war on drugs which actually
is now to come as well fighting the war
on terror but what's happening is so
much money is spent on fumigation on
searching for drug labs on getting rid
of the drug labs populations are being
affected all throughout Colombia that
coca pickers are often very poor
campesinos who are making their
livelihood from this they they pick the
cocaine leaves and I think you would
have a huge impact on
me because people who are doing that
would it be performing an illegal they
would be growing an illegal crops would
say and all it soft and hard in many of
the areas that are very remote to grow
other crops this is a crop that's very
easy to grow it grows very easily
there's people who will come up and come
to you and pick up the cocaine base so
there's a lot of advantages for people
to grow it actually and that the
actually the consumption of it in the US
and Europe around the world that's the
demand that's driving it as well